hi everyone welcome back to nostalgia
trip the show where we take a look back
at our favorite games from yesterday and
see if they still hold up today I'm Mike
McCarty here with Jordan and we are
looking back at a game that's coming up
on its 10th anniversary from a
now-defunct studio a game many of you
have played and loved and everyday are
asking for a remaster let's get into it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
in October 2017 publisher Electronic
Arts announced it was shuttering
Visceral Games at the time of its
closure the studio was home to Amy
Hennig director of Uncharted Fame who
was leading development on a Star Wars
project codenamed ragtag the game's
development was moved to another studio
and with that visceral was no more but
of course it's legacy continued despite
its modern reputation for sports titles
and microtransactions publisher
Electronic Arts has taken its fair share
of creative and financial risks
throughout its history chief among those
is the dead space trilogy heavily
influenced by Capcom's Resident Evil 4
dead space would go on to become one of
the most iconic horror franchises in the
medium it was then in 2008 that visceral
games then known only as EA Redwood
Shores first brought us to the USG
Ishimura right Jordan room a you and I
both like dead space a lot oh yeah
came out 10 years ago obviously there's
the trilogy of games dead space 1
through 3 and they change a lot the
series changes over those entries but I
want to talk about how Dead Space 1 is
very much a horror game compared to 2
and especially 3 but you just replayed
that space one recently what's it like
going back to it it's amazing how well
that game still holds up I mean I know
it's only been 10 years but horror video
games are just so difficult to create
just because you need to get that
up-and-down valley of creating dread and
then creating that scare to kind of give
the player enough time to build up that
dread again and dead space does that
brilliantly still ten years later just
with the fact of Necromorphs hiding on
the ground at the occasional jump scare
but typically dead space is a little bit
smarter with how it scares the player
yeah and I also love the first 10
minutes of that game especially when
you're coming in and you first see the
issue Moreau with Isaac who's the silent
protagonist in the first game we thought
about that a little more later as you
first come on to the mining vessel and
they set up the stakes they set up the
tone they set up like the first time you
fight a Necromorph right now you see
written in blood on the walls that would
say like aim for the limbs that game
does such a good job of setting up like
for shadows everything within the first
and that's like an amazing it's like a
like the first alien does it and we can
get into those comparisons if you want
to because from alien to aliens it's
essentially to jump from dead space
wanted dead space - yeah I mean this
game is just about just this ordinary
guy like even when you're just getting
off the ship you're looking at the suit
like I think his helmet has armor on it
but the rest of the suit is just kind of
just a standard space suit and the
weapon he uses is not something that you
would find in many poor shooters though
plasma cutter is kind of now famous for
what it is this kind of every man's tool
that's used to great effect I just love
the fact that they set it up so well
that you kind of see the Necromorphs in
action before isaac even has to deal
with them so it's not like you go
immediately onto the ship you get
attacked and suddenly Isaac's this
action here you kind of see behind this
pane of glass the Necromorphs killing
off the two nameless people actually
they probably have names but I've
totally forgotten about them because
they die in like two minutes
yeah you watch them die and you kind of
get an idea of how the Necromorphs act
and then just that saying later cut off
their limbs that's written in blood
giving you all you need to figure out
like there's something on the ship it's
very dangerous and don't go for
headshots cuz that's not gonna work for
you obviously that game does an amazing
job of keeping all of its HUD and its UI
diegetic the ammo the your health is all
on his rig hold still Isaac I'm sinking
of everyone's rig with the ship
okay we're done clean bill of health for
everyone
it's a third-person game but it's
immersive as hell oh yeah it's like even
when you pull up the map the game
doesn't even technically pause at that
point like enemies can still attack II
which makes it really nerve-wracking
really okay I need to figure out where
to go next but I need to kind of find
like a safe corner to chill out to
quickly look through my ammo and my
health packs and see where I'm supposed
to be going yeah as far as it also being
a horror game it's one of the few games
that I really enjoyed reading front to
cover the art book the apparently for if
you look at the issue Mara if you look
at eyes acrylic at a lot of the design
of the machinery in the game so much of
it was inspired by animal carcasses
their ribs if you look at his rig it's
very much like rib like and so much of
that goes into the design of the game on
like I maybe like even a subconscious
level but also like in just an aesthetic
level - I love that as you go through
the games obviously they get more
action-oriented especially when you get
to Dead Space 3 and you're all out of
action and that's also that's a whole
separate conversation about
microtransactions and whatnot but
playing back through dead space it did
you still find that the pacing holds up
you know dead space where's its resident
evil like origins on its leave and the
pacing still holds up very well
enemies are introduced a little slow at
first but over time they start ramping
up and the player kind of has to deal
more so with the environment than the
types of enemies that they encounter
which i think does a really good job of
helping with the pacing because
regardless of which difficulty you play
dead space on you have to contend with
the same environment throughout and
trying to deal with that slowly makes
the game more difficult over time
there's also currencies and like credits
and power nodes that upgrade your rig
and you know like you don't have a
merchant that sounds like what are you
buying but you have those terminals I
love doing the all plasma cutter run
mm-hmm but there is the aspect of kind
of every once in a while you hit a
checkpoint and it builds so well
throughout the game that you when you
reach one of those stations off the tram
you just feel safe I'm gonna say there's
a yes I love the weaponry in this game
like you said it fits really well into
Isaac Clark the everyman especially in
this first game it's he's very subdued
he doesn't have a voice he's a voiceless
protagonist
for like one line or something or no you
see its face like good but later on the
trilogy obviously you start to get to
know him more and I like what they did
with his character but he is very much
just this engineer that got brought
along on the trip he's like this Bruce
Willis from die hard or he's not this
superhero
it is a massive bummer because looking
back visceral is shuttered now
unfortunately people still everyday it
seems like you're asking for a
remastered collection I am among those
people saying I absolutely love them but
I think the main question I want to ask
you if I was first off if I was
unfamiliar with dead space mm-hmm is it
still worth playing today whether it's
backwards compatible on Xbox one or just
going back to play it on its original
console oh absolutely
still holds up perfectly well 10 years
after release survival horror games are
few and far between nowadays and I do
feel like maybe they didn't reach their
pinnacle with dead space and that's
based too but I do think that was like
you know the heyday of those kind of
games that third person survival horror
like I said there are games you could
play today but there aren't enough where
I would say like ignore dead space at
all because they like it was the
precursor to so much of this right like
it was heavily inspired by resting
before but I feel like the fact that
it's still a miracle that EA Electronic
Arts the company if you look at that
space 3 we associate so much with micro
transactions with battlefront games and
everything they do with Ultimate Team
and FIFA and Madden I it's still amazing
that we got these games and I still
think it's worth going back to just to
see this point in history for survival
horror for EA in general hopefully we're
past the microtransaction phase again
that's a different conversation with
three but I cannot stop thinking about
how awesome would be to have like the
Dead Space trilogy on ps4 or PC nowadays
and I really hope we get that soon I
would say I really want more games like
dead space the third-person horror game
it seemed like around the time that Dead
Space 3 was on its way out the entire
like scary video game genre was aiming
towards what outlast is what PT was
going to be the kind of first-person not
really walking simulator but kind of
walking around trying to survive that
way and I miss games like dead space I
want games like dead space again and
remastering it would be an easy way to
bring it back to get new players playing
again
you
[Music]